There's something about treasure that
capture every imagination,
maybe it's our love for adventure or our
love for solving puzzles,
or maybe it's just the anxiety of
knowing that something's out there
waiting to be found in the mid 19
seventies in England,
they're renowned publisher Tom Maschler
approached a little known painter by the
name of Kit Williams.
If the idea of making a children's
picture book maschler when it's
something that no one had ever done
before,
but Williams was resistant to the idea.
He didn't want to work on a dozen or
more paintings,
only to have people flip through them
casually.
How could he get readers to give his
pictures the attention they deserve
without telling maschler Williams came
up with the idea of a puzzle book
containing 16 original paintings that
had clues to the location of the 18
karat gold rabbit that he constructed
himself and buried somewhere in England.
Now the has been buried for.
The book was called masquerade.
It was published in 1979 and it was a
massive hit.
It went completely crazy.
We thought we'd have enough till
Christmas and we reprinted a further
50,000
a day off to publication and three days
later,
yet another $50,000,
I've really never seen it,
but blanket thousands,
tens of thousands,
hundreds of thousands of people set
about solving the puzzle of masquerade.
A year went by and to and still nobody
had cracked it,
but Williams was receiving huge numbers
of letters every day,
which she was forced to read or at least
skim through so he could confirm whether
anyone had solved it.
This package,
this has been going on for so long.
Then
in March 1982,
a little over two and a half years after
Williams buried the hair,
he received a letter from a man named
Ken Thomas.
The letter didn't have any insight into
how the puzzle system worked in
masquerade,
but there was a crude map that pointed
to the exact place where the treasure
was hidden.
Williams relieved at this point told him
that he was right and said,
go dig it up.
The puzzle of masquerade is completely
unique.
Williams invented it himself so that
theoretically anyone of any age could
figure it out.
Here's how it works.
Every page feature is at intricately
designed picture surrounded by an order
with a phrase.
The trick was to identify every living
creature in the frame and trace a line
from its left I through its lefthand.
It's right,
I threw its right hand,
it's left,
I threw its left foot and it's right,
it's right foot.
These lines would point to letters and
the border that could be anjem tumbled
into a word in this case burden.
If you follow this pattern for all 15
pages,
you'd end up with a master phrase that
goes like this.
Catherine's long finger overshadows
birth,
buried yellow ambulant midday points.
The Hour.
In light of equinox,
look to figure out what this means.
You have to take the first letter from
each pages word or words and string them
together.
If you do that,
you get close by and that's it.
MTL refers to the town of mtl about an
hour north of London,
and Catherine's long finger refers to
the tall cross that commemorates
Katherine of Aragon,
first wife of King Henry,
the eighth,
located in Mtl Park at noon on the
equinox.
The Sun projects a shadow of that cross
onto a specific spot in the grass.
That's where Williams hit the golden
hair.
No,
I never found it,
and that's how kit Williams,
masquerade golden hair was finally
found,
except there's a problem.
There is no Ken Thomas,
you see,
six years after the nationwide search
was over the Sunday Times in Britain
with the help of a local paper and Mtl
discovered that Ken Thomas was actually
a pseudonym for duke called Thompson,
who was the business partner of a man
named John Guard,
who at the time of masquerade was living
with Kit Williams ex-girlfriend,
Veronica Robertson.
Robertson had been to [inaudible] park
with Williams on a couple of occasions
and guests that might've had the prize,
their garden.
Thompson middle detected the whole area
dug holes,
but he couldn't find it.
It was only after they saw were two
physics teachers who had actually solve
the puzzle,
had been digging that they were able to
snatch the hair for themselves.
By the time everyone found out about
this scandal,
Thompson had already used the hair to
start a video game company called hair
soft.
Its flagship title.
Hair razor was a puzzle game that
promise the real golden hair to the
winter game is pretty much
incomprehensible in hilarious video on
hair racer,
comedian stuart ash,
and details why it's probably
unsolvable.
I'll leave a link to it below.
Nevertheless,
by the time that the expo say on
masquerade came out in [inaudible] 88,
the company had gone bankrupt and the
golden hair was sold by Southerby's at
auction for 32,000
pounds.
No one knows who bought it though the
BBC did track it down for a documentary
on Williams in 2009 after which it went
back to its owners to live in secrecy.
Once again,
nice.
Think she again,
never,
ever say that again.
Masquerade launched a new genre of
armchair treasure hunts like forest fens
million dollar chest of antiques,
hiding somewhere in the rocky mountains,
still unsolved,
and our love for hidden treasure is
clear in the popularity of books like
the Davinci Code or games like pokemon
go or in escape rooms which have
flourished across the world.
It's just fun to solve a puzzle and go
searching for treasure.
Still a declaration of independence.
Don't steal the declaration of
independence.
One of the questions that I get asked
all the time is what kind of program do
I use to put these videos together?
I use final cut pro 10 tate at the nerd
writer and there was actually a little
bit of a hubbub when 10 came out because
apple completely redesigned the program
from the previous version.
Final cut pro seven and editing tool
that I had used for over 10 years was
gone and it sucked,
but eventually I learned how to use
final cut pro 10 by watching a bunch of
youtube videos.
But what I really wish I had with
something like today's sponsor
skillshare.
Skillshare is an online learning
community for creators.
With more than 18,000
classes in things like graphic design,
animation,
web development,
and final cut pro 10,
all the classes are professional and
understandable and follow a clear
learning curve.
A premium membership begins around $10 a
month for unlimited access to all
courses,
but the first 500 people to sign up
using the link below in the description,
get their first two months for free,
and those two months you can easily
learn final cut pro or after effects any
kind of skill that you might need to
start a new hobby or business.
Definitely check it out guys.
It's a really great program.
Thanks again.
I'll see you next time.